[Música]
hola bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días este es
un magazine 100% dedicado al continente
africano mi nombre es andrés meza muñoz
y estos son nuestros titulares
el presidente de gambia adama barrow fue
reelegido para un segundo mandato en las
primeras elecciones presidenciales de
este país desde que el ex dictador yahyá
jammeh huyó al exilio los comicios son
considerados como una revalidación de la
democracia en un país que permaneció
durante 22 años bajo una dictadura
desde la detección de nuevos casos de la
variante o micro en alrededor del mundo
varios países de áfrica se apresuran a
reforzar sus campañas de vacunación esto
ante los temores por el surgimiento de
nuevas variantes del coronavirus sin
embargo no todos han podido acceder a
los fármacos y sólo el set 72 por ciento
del continente ha sido completamente
inoculado
panamá lleva a cabo una exhibición para
rendir homenaje a su ancestralidad como
afrodescendientes la llamada arte áfrica
presentará 198 piezas de hasta 100 años
de antigüedad provenientes de varios
países del continente en el marco de un
evento que busca la reconciliación con
la madre áfrica y su diáspora
empezamos en gambia donde el presidente
alemán fue reelegido para un segundo
mandato las celebraciones en la capital
se prolongaron hasta bien entrada la
noche cuando barro ganó por un margen
abrumador esta fue la primera elección
presidencial del país desde que el es
dictador yahyá jammeh huyó al exilio y
aunque los resultados son disputados por
la oposición los comicios significan un
nuevo capítulo para la democracia de
esta pequeña nación de áfrica occidental
victoria los partidarios de la dama
burroughs se reunieron en el centro de
la capital banjul para celebrar el
inicio de su segundo mandato
barrow fue reelegido frente a su
oponente y saludar boe con más del 50%
de los votos sus partidarios expresaron
su alegría
al celebrar siento feliz me siento feliz
porque mi presidente el que elegí ya ha
ganado por eso estoy tan contenta todo
el mundo en cambia está de fiesta por el
presidente todos estamos contentos el
presidente se unió a sus seguidores y
llamó a la unidad en la pequeña nación
de áfrica occidental
hago un llamado a todos los gambianos
independientemente de todas las
divisiones para que dejemos de lado
nuestras diferencias políticas y de otro
tipo y nos unamos como un solo pueblo
para trabajar por el desarrollo de
nuestro país les doy las gracias que
dios los bendiga siempre sin embargo no
todo el mundo está celebrando ya quedar
boe y otros candidatos dicen que no
aceptarán los resultados
citaron como motivo de sospecha el largo
retraso en el anuncio de los tres
estados
rechazamos los resultados anunciados
hasta ahora nos reservamos el derecho de
emprender cualquier acción que la
situación requiera para ello todas las
posibilidades están sobre la mesa
fueron las primeras elecciones en casi
30 años en las que no participó el ex
dictador yahyá jammeh pero sus sombras
sigue planeando sobre el país y él mismo
conserva un importante apoyo político
los 22 años de gobierno de yale
estuvieron marcados por acusaciones de
detenciones arbitrarias torturas
violaciones y ejecuciones una comisión
de la verdad creada por baró para
investigar los presuntos abusos
cometidos bajo el gobierno de james
pidió que los responsables comparezcan
ante la justicia pero será recién
reelegido presidente quien decida si
sigue esas recomendaciones
mientras más países continúan
registrando nuevos casos de la variante
omicron detectada en sudáfrica varias
naciones de áfrica buscan evitar la
propagación de este nuevo linaje del
coronavirus y hasta el surgimiento de
nuevas variantes a través de distintas
campañas de vacunación pretenden
inocular a sus ciudadanos pero no todos
los países del continente han podido
darse este lujo
un nuevo impulso para hacer frente a un
micrón varios países de áfrica han
buscado acelerar sus campañas de
vacunación ante los temores sobre la
propagación de la nueva variante de
coronavirus en nigeria por ejemplo las
autoridades recurren a líderes
religiosos en iglesias mezquitas y en
oficinas gubernamentales para persuadir
a las personas de aplicarse el fármaco
[Música]
vine a la iglesia y fue una oportunidad
para ponerme la vacuna he estado
buscando la manera de aplicarme la imm
había ninguna vacuna disponible
y si te vas
en egipto se han instalado puestos de
vacunaciones en tres comerciales
estaciones de metro clubes deportivos y
centros juveniles lo que ha facilitado
su acceso
[Música]
ahora hagamos hacer que las vacunas
estén disponibles en lugares cercanos al
lugar o al trabajo ahorre esfuerzo y
tiempo en lugar de tener que viajar o
esperar en algún lugar
final para quedar un poco
lo mismo ha hecho sudáfrica donde fue
detectada de la nueva variante el número
de personas que hace fila para recibir
la vacuna se ha disparado en medio de
una campaña con la que busca agilizar la
inoculación pero ante la escasez de
vacunas en áfrica no todos los países
han podido garantizar la inoculación el
presidente sudafricano cyril ramaphosa
condenó a las naciones ricas por
acaparar los fármacos algo que calificó
como codicia
a diamantes trade sing the arts on line
tres sets están demostrando que sólo
están interesados en promover los
intereses de sus ciudadanos no los
ciudadanos de todo el mundo y este es el
tipo de aparte de vacunación que decimos
debe llegar a su fin that we se más
camps tienen según la organización
mundial de la salud sólo el 7,2 por
ciento de la población del continente
está completamente vacunado los expertos
insisten en que las campañas de
vacunación serán necesarias para poner
fin a la pandemia y que las bajas tasas
de inoculación fomentaría en la
propagación de mutaciones virales como
la nueva variante omicron
en nigeria las autoridades del estado de
lagos rechazaron las conclusiones de una
investigación judicial que determinó que
se había producido una masacre durante
una represión contra los manifestantes
del año pasado las protestas de starz
comenzaron rechazando la brutalidad
policial y luego se convirtieron en las
manifestaciones antigubernamentales más
grandes un año después mientras las
fuerzas de seguridad continúan negando
cualquier responsabilidad muchas de las
víctimas están tratando de seguir
adelante un equipo de france 24 fue a
reunirse con algunos de ellos
este cuarto es el único lugar donde
patrick se siente seguro hace cuatro
meses huyó de su casa una noche cuatro
hombres vestidos de civil tocaron a las
puertas de todos sus vecinos para
localizarlo desde entonces el joven ya
no sale tras la represión del 20 de
octubre de 2020 en lagos vive aquí
aterrorizado con una bala alojada en su
cuerpo cerca del codo derecho
según la radiografía mi médico dice que
la bala está por aquí cerca de mi codo
pero he tenido mucha suerte no me ha
tocado ninguna arteria ni ninguna vena
así que todavía según él viviré para
siempre con esta bala en mi cuerpo
porque si intento alguna operación
podría afectar el uso de mi mano derecha
extensión de la misma
y patrick sobrevivió a sus heridas el
hermano de nataniel no tuvo esa suerte
la comisión independiente de
investigación iniciada por el gobernador
de lagos reconoció su muerte el 20 de
octubre de 2020
esta comisión sugiere que se pague una
indemnización de unos 54 mil euros a
nataniel y a su madre pero el estado de
lagos se niega a seguir esta
recomendación desde la desaparición de
su hermano pequeño nataniel está
profundamente deprimido
desde que perdí a mi hermano perdí la
concentración me siento muy solo no
tengo a nadie en quien confiar sobretodo
mi hermano pequeño me respeta mucho
nunca me ha desobedecido me ha ayudado
mucho
de los 255 expedientes de presuntas
víctimas la comisión de investigación
conservo 182 muchos de los cuales
estuvieron representados por el abogado
avecina o burlan a
uno de sus clientes fue atacado con un
machete por hombres no identificados
otros han recibido amenazas
no tenemos que tener miedo no somos
inmigrantes estamos en nuestra patria y
vale la pena el riesgo de morir por
nigeria y si tenemos que pasar por esto
para romper la opresión porque hay
matones frente a nosotros entonces nos
enfrentaremos a esos matones
spandau todas las víctimas del
movimiento en sears saben que el
reconocimiento de su condición de
víctimas va a ser una larga lucha el
estado de lagos rechaza las conclusiones
de la comisión de investigación
independiente y al menos dos ministros
del gobierno federal han negado
cualquier implicación del ejército y la
policía en la represión del 20 de
octubre de 2020 pasamos a panamá que se
prepara para recibir a reyes y reinas y
jefes tribales de áfrica en un evento al
que han bautizado viaje de expiación y
reconciliación de la madre áfrica y
reunión con su diáspora que tendrá lugar
en mayo como parte de ello ha lanzado
una exhibición denominada arte áfrica
que estará disponible hasta el próximo
14 de enero y en la que se mostrarán 198
piezas de hasta 100 años de antigüedad
pertenecientes a un coleccionista que ha
visitado distintos países del continente
como república democrática del congo
camerún gabón mal y tanzania burkina
faso nigeria y costa de marfil entre
otros de acuerdo con la secretaría
nacional para el desarrollo de los afro
panameños esta exhibición pretende
conocer la vida tradicional de personas
africanas que llegaron durante un
proceso de colonización y para fomentar
su ancestralidad como afrodescendientes
panamá ha sido el punto escogido por su
posición geográfica e históricas podemos
a través de ella
visualizar la vida de nuestros hermanos
africanos y poder entender lo que somos
a través de cada una de ellas y cada una
de las piezas las formas rituales las
formas de la maternidad las formas de
cuidarse las formas de la salud se ve
refleja reflejada en cada una de estas
piezas que van a poder ver qué
cada cultura representaba algo diferente
lo que eran sus tradiciones su religión
en que utilizado en cada cultura algunas
la utilizaban para venerar a sus dioses
a tener a las personas importantes
dentro de sus tribus como guerreros o
mujeres fuertes dentro de sus tribus que
representaban algo algo muy importante y
despedimos este capítulo de áfrica siete
días con imágenes exquisitos que llegan
desde túnez donde se celebra la quinta
edición del festival magrebí del cuscús
un plato tradicional en la región del
magreb y áfrica sub-sahariana elaborado
con sémola de grano al vapor y que se
suele servir como base para guisos con
verduras o carne el cuscús le ha dado la
vuelta al mundo y en diciembre de 2020
fue incluido en la lista del patrimonio
cultural inmaterial de la unesco
con estas imágenes despedimos este
capítulo de áfrica siete días recuerden
que si quieres repetir esta u otra
emisión de nuestro programa lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
punto frente 4 punto com
[Música]